Speaker 1: All right. Well, Tim Scott's
Republican presidential candidacy off to
an explosive start opening the event
in North Charleston, South Carolina,
with a Dean scream. I'll explain in a moment.
Then, plagued by audio issues you all know, I love
it when these right wingers have audio issues.
Speaker 2: That included the largest agricultural
resource of our farm product.
Speaker 1:
Exactly right. And then just saying completely
outrageous things. And his campaign does appear
to be dead on arrival. So as I told you yesterday,
Republican Senator from South Carolina, Tim Scott,
the only black Republican in the Senate,
has announced he is running for president
of the United States against Donald Trump. Why
MAGA voters would switch from a candidate who
regularly scapegoats black and brown people to
a black guy. I don't know. It doesn't seem like
that's going to appeal to them. But here is Tim
Scott opening the event with the Dean scream.
Speaker 2: Oh, no joking.
Speaker 1: And for people
who don't remember the Dean scream, this was
the moment in 2014 that ended Howard Dean's
presidential chances. And I'm not saying
it was right. I'm just saying it happened.
And then we're.
Speaker 2: Going to
Washington, D.C. to take back the White House.
Speaker 1: Exactly. A moment that will live in
infamy. Tim Scott in very melodramatic
fashion. This is all so stupid, guys,
in melodramatic fashion building to the big
announcement. And I guess you could say the
crowd went wild. I don't know. You tell me.
Speaker 2: Not less. We cannot have innocent
people at risk. Police officers getting ambushed
in attack and seniors locked in their homes. From
the time the sun goes down until the sun comes
up, Joe Biden and the radical left are attacking
every single rung of the ladder that helped
me climb. And that's why I'm announcing today.
That I'm running.
Unidentified: For President
of the United States of America.
Speaker 1:
So anyway, certainly a lot
of energy there happening.
And he also made the strange claim that he's
the candidate, the lefties most scared of,
which is interesting.
Speaker 2: I'm the candidate.
The far left fears the most.
Speaker 1: The far left is like,
Who are you again?
Speaker 2:
You think? Well, I cut your taxes. They called
me a prop. Oh, well, I refunded the police.
They called me a token. Well, I've
pushed back on President Biden.
They even called me the N-word.
Speaker 1: The audience is like.
Speaker 2: I just from their narrative, I
threaten their control. The truth of my life
disrupts their lives.
Speaker 1: There you go.
I don't know that the Republican audience
is going to go for this. That's my sense,
folks. And we'll look at the polling in a
moment. I can't gloss over the massive audio
issues that they had and I'm actually going to
play for you. It feels like it goes on forever,
but it doesn't. I love this stuff.
Speaker 2: America is not a nation.
Speaker 1: Oh. So the audio has now cut out.
Someone starts signaling him. He's asking which
microphone is causing the problem. He's tapping
his microphone. He's wearing a lapel mic and
holding one. He's switching it on and off. Now he
steps forward. It's getting awkward. He's talking
into it, but it's totally dead. He seemed to check
his feet as if he had, like, stepped on a cable.
And then now I guess someone is going to maybe
bring him a different mic. Okay. Now he's been
handed a third microphone. This one's wired and
it's also not working. He's talking into multiple
mikes now, and then he does. He's now he has
the mic reversed, almost about to talking to the
back end of the microphone and then tapping the
lapel, holding two mikes and wearing a third one.
Speaker 2: This is unbelievable. And now.
Speaker 1: There's cheering. Okay. And now
he's back. They were able to survive
the audio problems, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: But I think, Eric, they're not like
little people. They lived up. I used to check it
every week. Are they buying? Are they buying?
Speaker 1: Okay, so how? This is the dumbest
Republican primary. How is Tim Scott doing?
Not particularly. Well. He has opened up this
race with an explosive 1.8% support behind at
half the level of support of Vivek Ramaswamy,
well behind Nikki Haley and far behind
Mike Pence, who isn't even a candidate.
I think it's important to know. That being
said, Tim Scott is ahead of Larry Elder,
and I didn't even know Larry Elder was considering
running or that anyone was thinking of Larry Elder
as a candidate. But needless to say, 1.8%. It is
undeniable that Tim Scott's campaign is completely
dead on arrival. But there's someone that seems
to be gushing with excitement for Tim Scott,
and that's the crew over at Fox and Friends
on Fox News. Let's talk about that next